okay we are live what up guys welcome to
the just pearly things youtube channel
can you guys let me know in the chat
if you can hear me okay because i've
heard mixed thing oh no
i don't know mixed things about i like
so let me know in the chat that i am
good to go with my mic and then i will
get going
um
okay
anyone in the chat mike okay my good i
can push it back if it's too echoey
okay you live in orlando that is not
helpful to the question at hand the mic
how are we with the mic
okay okay so today um the topic that i
wanted to talk about
is high value men men of value famous
men whatever it is
are they worth it um so i have taken i
went through one of kevin samuel's
youtube videos
and
i looked up the definition of a high
value man so they have to make 10k per
month
and that is adjusted based on where they
live so if they live somewhere like san
francisco
la chicago whatever it is they have to
adjust their income for making more
um they can't just have gotten on this
money quick they have to have been
making this money from between three to
five years
um
group acceptance by other high value men
so other high value men have to
recognize him as a peer
um he has a network of high value men
and others
um
sorry okay and he has to have visibility
position and income our linkedin level
so the example that kevin samuels gave
in his broadcast is
like the ceo of aqua or the vp of
acquisitions and mergers
versus just an entrepreneur you'd have
to have more information to know if the
entrepreneur is actually a high value
man
and use utility he's useful to others in
the group so just to give a little
background my dad i don't know if he
would be a high value man or a man of
value i would guess it's probably based
on who you ask
but in terms of income he makes in the
top half a percent of earners he started
his own software company he did that for
25 years and sold it so that's
i don't know the definition of
so i i the reason i don't automatically
put my dad in with high value men is
because my dad really
keeps to himself he doesn't have a lot
of friends like
but he he does have work people that he
works with and he does have a network of
people that are successful so
and that he works with but
he's not really into the
uh
lifestyle i guess the fast like life
like we live on 40 acres we don't go to
events that are crazy
so i i don't know take it or leave it
man of value a high value man
um okay so what but when i listen to
girls talk about what they want in a guy
i don't think they understand what
they're signing up for when you date one
of these guys um
now i was going to start with the pros
of dating a high value man man of value
you know nba player entertainer whatever
it is whatever your
definition guy that sought after is
so the pros is you have a guy that other
women want right i mean what girl
like no girl wants a guy that no other
girl wants sorry
um often times you're not gonna have to
work
money um
isn't really going to be a factor for
you
you have the ability to stay at home
with the kids a lot of people aren't
going to have that you have a competent
husband and before i keep going i know a
lot of you are going to say that
entertainers don't automatically fall
into this category i know but the reason
i'm including entertainers in this
broadcast is because
i mean how many girls chase after guys
with the blue check mark let's just
let's just be real here in terms of you
know smv and
guy
guys that girls want
okay
so i'm gonna talk about the cons of
dating these guys and being part of that
world and then i'm gonna put the link in
the chat and you guys can call in and
let me know what you think so
uh my ex-boyfriend was like very well
known very famous and the one thing that
you don't realize when you date someone
that is on a high level and a high
platform is that you have to deal with a
level of insecurity that you really like
didn't have before
so
you know that in the click of a button
that guy could have 20 girls at his
apartment like that
he never did anything there was never
any you know cheating or anything like
that but
there there's a level of security that
you just like lose and there's a level
of insecurity i would consider myself a
relatively secure person i'm not the
type that needs to you know
go on only fans or like flat like flash
their butt or whatever for validation
um
but you know it's hard not to be
somewhat insecure in that situation and
a lot of girls
i i don't think are ready
for that conversation
um second thing
if you are not in the same social class
as that high value man there's always
going to be a piece of you that doesn't
feel like you belong
my parents did not grow up
rich they grew up poor
and at certain events that we would go
to
you just don't feel like you fit in and
there's no other way to describe it but
you go to these events and everyone
talks a certain way everybody acts a
certain way and if you don't know how to
like fit in in these communities and
carry yourself in a certain way like you
feel so much on the outside and this is
coming from someone i grew up
very well in most situations
i i can fit in in a room most of it i
would say like 90 of situations but
there's certain like private banking
events that we've gone to where i just
felt
so i don't know
alienated like
by by yourself almost
and
if you date someone in a higher social
class than you like you are always going
to feel like you are adapting to their
world
um okay
the third thing women don't understand
about high value men is you can be
replaced easily these men have access to
women
and you
you we often hear about how high value
men don't cheat the exercise options
half the time those options is just the
pressure of knowing your guy can replace
you like that
in a second
because
a lot of times these guys are a bit cold
because you have to be a little bit cold
to get to the top and if you're not
doing the things that you're supposed to
be doing as a wife
as a girlfriend as a mother
they will replace you they will
and
that's a level of security
do you want that type of pressure on a
relationship where if you have a couple
if you have a bad year if you're going
through something you have that pressure
that you can be replaced is that
something you want
some girls the benefits outweigh the
cost but that is something that you have
to think about
okay the next thing
these guys do not want a girl that is
sitting around and doing nothing
that that's not attractive to them
if you get a high value man and a guy
that makes that kind of money they want
something in return
like that is the biggest lie my mom
would not have married my dad and stayed
married to my dad if she did not work
for him if she did not cook if she did
not clean that marriage would have
dissolved that would have ended
like a lot of these girls think they're
gonna marry one of these guys
and just get to be a housewife get to do
nothing no that's not how it works it's
not
um
you might get to be a housewife but you
are going to be a hard-working housewife
um for example my mom planned all of our
vacations all the vacations that we went
on
my mom planned and
plant and coordinated everything every
last detail of them she organized
all of our
clothes our hand-me-downs everything for
nine kids that stuff is not easy
it's not okay
and okay the last
the last thing that you have to realize
about
dating high value man or men of value is
you will never have all of them ever
these guys don't they're workaholics
they don't turn that off my dad this
year last year almost died because he
literally almost worked himself to death
so my mom's been waiting her whole life
to just retire with this guy
with my dad but that [ __ ] doesn't go
away you don't
turn off the part of your brain that's a
workaholic and a little bit crazy
it just it doesn't go away and
a lot of times these girls think they're
going to be getting high levels of
attention but
you can't have everything if you want a
guy that gives you
a ton of attention pick a less
successful guy
and another thing that girls don't
realize is a lot of these guys are cheap
they're not just going to be showering
you with gifts my mom didn't get a
present
on christmas for 10 plus years now she
has you know six figure jewelry and a
bunch of [ __ ]
but like the idea that you guys are just
going to marry into these families and
you're just going to be showered with
gifts
you are going to do nothing you are just
going to be a housewife and raise the
kids and
oh my gosh
no you're that's not how it works these
men make a lot of money they want
something in return and ladies what do
you have to offer what do you have to
bring to the table
um
and it's not always necessarily what you
think
um my mom when they got married she
really wasn't the best cook she really
she told me she wasn't neat but she
worked hard so the stuff that she had to
get better at she figured out
and that's a trait that that is the
number one trait that i see men
overlooking in a wife because
a lot of guys don't want a girl that's
competitive with them true but do you
want someone that's lazy
and and guys aren't necessarily
attracted to work ethic i don't think
like that doesn't turn them on
but it's
i think a lot of times that is where
they get screwed over because you have a
girl that doesn't want to work and she
wants your money and she wants
you know
to take advantage of you but what do you
guys think i'm about to drop the link in
the chat
and you guys can join
all your moms feels neglected
exactly if uh if men showers females
with girly they get used for money
um yeah
and these guys are not stupid
um
and that's the thing
so
so many girls just think it drives me
insane when i see these girls
thinking they're just going to be a
housewife and do nothing and
i really want to
also bring back that
if you are not in that person's social
class you will always have to feel like
you are losing a part of yourself you
just will you're not going to be you're
not going to fit in in their world and
you will have to work to figure out how
to fit in
um so is it worth it
for some
also if you guys hear anything that is
my dog snoring in the background
um
okay
hi
what's going on pearl so you were asking
are high value men worth it
yes
yeah i mean i think well when you say
worth it do you mean just are you
talking about like cheating or are you
talking about just worth like
just working for some were you talking
about specifically well i'm talking
about everything so when you get a high
value man
it it's a lot of pressure you're not
just going to be sitting there being a
housewife and doing nothing you're going
to have to work hard and you're going to
have to work for him a lot of the time
and go by his rules
and that could include cheating it also
could not like my dad doesn't cheat at
my mom he doesn't do that
um so
what do you think
um yeah i think it's worth it i think
the higher caliber you go with anything
like harvard of course harvard should be
harder to get into the unc greensboro
you know
it should be more difficult to go to a
higher level school or deal with a
higher level person of any type in any
area i think it's worth it but the
problem is is
like when someone says they want a high
value man
why do you sit why do you want a high
value person if a female came to me and
said i want a high value man or she said
i want a man who makes x amount of
dollars i mean automatically i wouldn't
want to deal with her like you marry
people for
character and intensity
then that's just a bonus like
hey my man makes a lot of money like
that's that's a bonus that's something
to be happy about but you don't go in
thinking oh
i want to marry a high value man because
what that says to me is you just want to
be able to spend somebody else's money
and do what you yeah
yeah and a lot of times girls don't
realize money can come and go so the
guy's work ethic is so much more
important than if he has money or not
um yeah there's been there's been times
in my dad's career where he's been like
flat broke but he'll always out work so
i'll work the next guy so it's just
never been a problem
when you're an entrepreneur or when you
work for yourself or do your own thing
you're gonna go through high points and
low points this is a different type of
lifestyle and yeah the thing that i
think is ridiculous is all the a lot of
these people they want the man after
he's been going through all that and
ain't nobody that's a thing the men that
you want
99 of them they don't want you because
if they're good enough now after all
that they had to go through that just
shows your intentions and what happens
is a lot of these females they can have
see sex is different for us
see
the same way how we are we playing
basketball oh you can play basketball i
don't have to know your name i ain't got
to know where you're from i just can't
play basketball see his females they
will sleep with a high value man and
they think they're on that level and
that's the standard for marriage before
sex and marriage and emotional
connection
is just totally different
and to what you were saying about um
there was a good point you were saying
about how uh it was something serious
about how high value men like how your
dad didn't cheat and how i'm trying to
remember what you said because i had a
good point
oh yeah that's right it's about the
money okay yeah first of all
just because
somebody makes six figures
a year
they could be financially worse off than
somebody making 30k a year because do
you know how to save it what about your
debt
you could end up having nothing
and that's the thing and i've tried to
explain this in the community where i'm
from it is so looked down upon to be
like flashy with your money i know
someone worth 50 million he's driven the
same car for 20 years
like 50 million that's that's very well
off
and
that's what people don't understand is
they think like by flashing this money
it's some sort of status symbol
and it's really not like in the
community i'm from at least it's
it's almost like a way to show you're
financially irresponsible
yeah you're exactly right and that's why
like and i always say this
i don't think a lot of these females i
don't even think
just because of that they don't have a
place to talk about how much a man needs
to make when it comes to making money
pearl because a lot of these females
first of all they don't it don't matter
what area of life it's in
they don't understand the psychology of
somebody who is a high earning person if
i bring out a high earning person from
every area of life unless they hit the
lotto they all have a similar attitude
yes i don't know the psychology they
don't know the psychology of the person
not only do they not know the psychology
of the person but they don't know how
much how money works in terms of risk
and reward and budgeting and not getting
yourself into debt you know just things
like that and how and how
money can be taken from you mm-hmm well
and if you're dating
especially if you're dating an
entrepreneur like that comes with a
level of of risk too yes like like my
dad he invested him and my mom's
invested their life savings into uh they
bought a neighborhood right before 2008.
so they lost everything but that's like
a level of risk you sign up for but
these girls these girls think it's just
going to be a free easy ride and it's
not
and that's the biggest
misconception i see john do you have
anything to add i see you're muted
yeah can you hear me
yeah hi
yeah
um i wanted to say is a lot of the time
what i've noticed is a lot of young
women they they look at all like the
shiny things
hey john john john um i don't know
what's going on with your mic but it's
very echoey do you have headphones oh
yeah
yeah i'm um
i'm in a really echoey room that's all
okay if you could maybe bring the mic
like closer to your face or something if
you can or you have headphones maybe
uh it's a little better yeah
yeah um i'm going to say
what i've noticed is a lot of young
women want to they see that all shiny
things and think if i can get a guy like
that
i can have all of those
all of the shiny things like vacations
expensive dinners
but unknowingly they don't know the kind
of
well and that's what
the richest people i know do not spend
money like that they do not
and that's what people
is a really big misconception with girls
like a lot of times they think that the
richest guy in the room is the one that
has the flashy things
and
sometimes it is you know i'm not i'm not
going to act like i know every rich
person out there but what is bill gates
like where to work every day and same
with like half of these billionaires
okay john um your mic do you have
headphones or something because like i
think you have to someone said reduce
the gain on your mic maybe
i didn't like settings i can hear you
can you hear me now
it's a little better yeah go ahead
yeah
i was like i was going to say is i was
going to say like
i was going to say
a lot of the times
i was going to say a lot of the times if
basically if you want if you want to
i've always said that i've always said
that um
life
and life are always
consequences unintended or infinite
consequences yeah
yes
and i also always said i've
always said that life got hands life
life will beat you beat you up and steal
your chips so
it just depends just it just depends
some women are smart enough to get into
a marriage where
life is like easier
some aren't
[Music]
it's it's i because
it's
i believe you know this fact that a lot
of a lot of black women like i think i
think one in four are likely to get
married
mm-hmm
it's not to me that's honestly kind of
sad if i'm honest
yeah
yeah um are you are you on speaker by
chance someone said that in the chat
oh wow
i'm just talking out loud
okay
his
voice is echoing he's not coming in as
clear but we can hear him okay i mean
it's fine for now but i was just seeing
if we could make it better
um
okay so do you think that for the
average woman a high value man is worth
it yes or no
no
the reason why i say no is because
it
has to take a lot of
it'll have to take a lot of
sacrifice
and i don't think most women of on whose
average looking
will be willing to make that sacrifice
and if if i'm a guy if i work
10 to 15 years
my butt off by myself no one there by my
side any woman that comes any woman that
might come towards me am i likely to
marry them or take them seriously not
really
not really
because i work i worked my butt off you
weren't there you said no to me back
then so yeah
i'm not just going to smash and dip off
right or
well from
dip off
and
i think a lot of them they can have
aiming for it meaning like if he's
working his butt off and if he's by
handing him the brick building the
foundation
she might be able to she basically her
her time and attention
is likely
to be rewarded with a with a ring
right
right um okay wait i'm gonna unmute
marcus
marcus um are high value men worth it
yes or no for the average woman
oh wait maybe he's not okay never mind
well paul let me tell you something this
is real life experience right here
um i'm gonna start off with the
beginning so when i was in college a few
years ago
there was this girl in the soccer team
that i like i thought she was real cute
so i went up to an approach store in the
cafeteria area
so i went up to her and approached that
girl
and
she never looked at me or nothing she
just talked me a little bit
the rest of the team came is about for
her friends they're on the team too and
neither one of them looked at me you
know and i asked him like who do you all
like y'all ever going to parties and the
girls said we party with the baseball
team
now
that girl didn't bat an eye at me
she said she parted with the baseball
team
i've never seen any of those girls
hang out with anybody other than a male
athlete
so that just shows what female hypergamy
is and
at the time i was a guy who i was trying
different things entrepreneur build my
craft and whatnot
if you fast forward now last year i was
able to step away from my job because
i'm at a point where i'm making more
money than i would a job can't call
myself high value yet but i'm
financially doing better than the
overwhelming majority of people that i
graduated with
the point i'm trying to make is if a
woman
wants to be with the high value man how
many of y'all are trying to hear i come
home and say um i'm leaving my job i'm
quitting i'm good now are you gonna be
okay
with the fact that everything is relying
on me right now
that's why that like you said the
average woman she can't do it because
men like me who are going to be high
value you have to deal with our
risk-taking and a lot of women y'all
just don't have that like i faced so
much rejection
so much scrutiny to get to where i'm at
it's like are you gonna do that with me
i'm not an easy dude to be with mm-hmm
no that's so true that's because a lot
of these girls think it's gonna be an
easy ride and you know what
first some i'm sure it is i'm sure some
girls hit the jackpot whatever but
that's not the majority like if you date
an entrepreneur and a guy that makes a
lot of money it comes with high risk
because high risk is high reward yep and
some years are going to be low and are
you the type of girl that's going to
stick by his side are you going to run
the first second something gets hard
can i can i go now yeah go ahead
yeah yeah well what's up guys good
evening it's pretty dark out here in
california i know it's probably i don't
know what time it is over there for you
guys wherever you're at but hope the
best is going for you happy holidays
uh my point is on that um there's pros
and cons to everything there's there's
winners and losers and of course
obviously men
have to be very very careful with who
they marry and women have to be very
careful who they get pregnant by
that's those are the two main things i
think when it comes to that because a
woman can be going out the drug dealer
and he's a bad bad he's a bad example
not a good guy
you know a criminal
gangbanger but she gets pregnant by
chatter tyrone but you have the other
good guy who is successful responsible
has a good reputation honorable legacy
um some women tend to dismiss that
nowadays because they want the bad boy
lifestyle that the chat of tyrone
um
but you know hey um
you you reap what you sow and if a guy
wants to pick up the trash and litter
he's going to get trash and litter
results
if a guy wants to get a respectful woman
he's got to make sure he's smart on who
he
vets
also the women have to be trained
properly as well
and learn from appropriate women i say
women if they're single hang out with
married couples so that way she learns
from married couples how to be a
marriage because
duty comes first happiness comes second
or third for each couple
for each i'm sorry for each spouse the
husband and the wife
for duty it's it's duty responsibility
and then it's your happiness
and usually
the best way marriage can last is you do
your role
and you make the other people happy not
yourself
that entirety should make you happy
itself by making them happy
that's how it's going to work for the
relationship to last long
and it's going to be peaceful so that's
my experience on relationships that have
been successful they're marriages that
are very bitter together
um and i can speak for myself from my
parents because my mom was a shitty ass
wife to my dad but she was a goddamn
great good mother
but
but my father was the damn great example
of a true alpha value man
did his role his responsibility even
though he did not stand my mother he
still did what he had to do
and i respect the hell out of him for
that
no i agree with um what you said where
like happiness comes second i i think
our society today is so much instant
gratification
that like especially women like we think
this moment we're not happy in a
relationship it's just time to bounce or
the moment you're not happy especially
in a marriage when you have kids
you're going to break up your entire
family because you're not happy
it's interesting because a lot of girls
get get mad when i when i say this that
it's selfish to break up your home
um simply because you're not happy but
it genuinely is because you're literally
only thinking about your feelings
yes it is
um
yeah
okay
um
well
my parents my mom and dad actually
divorced
when i was a lot younger so yeah
well the great thing about it is my dad
me and my father still had a
relationship afterwards anyway
mm-hmm
one thing one thing i do like about my
father
is he
my father is he was he was almost always
there the only thing i liked about it
was always there
but
i don't know why my mom and dad broke up
though my mom
my mom said that because they got
married too early
and i mean
at that point i kind of noticed okay
it do make sense i think people should
get married a little later on in life
the reason why i said it is because when
you're younger
you tend to you tend to do you tend to
do stupid things
especially
yeah you tend to do
stupid things attentive a lot a lot of
the time so getting there when you're a
little older
allows you to
makes you capable of
basically
i started hopefully you know that
allows you to make us more faithful
non-decisional he used that to marry
mm-hmm
you know
i've always
and i've always said to certain men
don't let your need for intercourse
warp your sense of morality i've seen
that i've seen many times
mistake many dudes go out to married
women women in relationships and always
come back to fight them in the air
oh wait no
yeah
well if she cheats with you she'll cheat
on you
yeah
that's why
like it's not really respectable or or
she may not even cheat she'll just take
the money and disappear yeah
you know because i have heard i've heard
of cases where
um for example my experience in the
military when i was doing my stuff when
i was deployed you know you see the
movie jar head there was like a
scene there that displays the wall of
shame
and of women who have deserted their
husbands
while the men have been not deployed or
the woman bangs the brother or the
deployed soldier or the marine
um or she comes back home and all the
stuff is gone the money's gone she
cleaned out the account
it's a joint account
and she probably never even had a guy he
just took the money and she was just
like
uh i'm tired of waiting on him he's
dying for us he's willing to
give up his life and he has a kid here
supporting he's paying the bills but
i still am not grateful and i'm gonna
throw away that and take the money so
well and that's that's the thing that
women don't understand about high value
men i mean i can't i don't have really
any experience with like military men so
i like i have no idea with that but
you're never going to come first you are
never going to get his your his full
time and attention literally ever
i mean my mom's been waiting like 20
years for my dad to be retired and he
retired for six months and started
another company like it just
it's never going to end
yeah and women have to understand too
that for the majority of time the man is
a breadwinner
so um understand the economy you live in
the capitalistic country of america
because a lot of guys the ages moved up
older where you have to work even more
to retire older
and and so they have to be aware of that
not saying that they have to be on their
knees and stuff obviously no of course
not just be understandable if you don't
have patience you got to work on
patience people now just have to work on
their patience
and understanding and listening not
listening to respond but listening to
learn
and
uh no no go for it and go for dc
pearl i just wanted to uh i wanted to
say um thank you for your channel and
what you do because
um i i'm speaking on behalf of all three
men uh
we're we're tired of
the world blaming us
for everything wrong that's happened and
i'm not saying this out of anger and
frustration and being ugly
we're tired of the world blaming us for
everything wrong
when if if if a roof were to collapse at
a restaurant or if a shooter came into a
restaurant or if somebody started
choking we would be the first ones to go
and help
if anything if if we're in a situation
where it's a ride or die where we got to
go down fighting together we're going to
be the ones to do it not women so we're
tired of being looked at as the dumb
stupid no good when we have the most
noble characters whereas what
yeah
no you're absolutely right um and a lot
of times i think a girl's view of men is
more reflection on her than on men
because
it it all men aren't trash clearly so
it's your ability to pick
and and if you if you're jaded and you
hate men and you think they're the
problem like it says a hell of a lot
more about you than it does about men
yes it does
yeah yeah yeah and and again like uh
i as much as i agree with you i'm also
very empathetic and have a big heart and
when i help people a lot
so
uh trauma something serious ptsd is
something serious
um surviving something very very intense
or crazy can be something very serious
to learn from
so i understand that some of these
wounds we carry their scars that we
carry whether you're we're enlisted or a
civilian or not they're as far as we
carry all around us regardless of the
job for the we're in
uh where our bringings our race where we
grow up whether it's black latino white
social economic tax bracket
um even though here in america
there's a weird is weird because
they say that once you earn up to more
than 80 000
you're not that happy and improvement of
happiness doesn't really rise at all
uh and i noticed that when you become
the middle income tax
you get taxed a lot actually when you
become the middle tax bracket you get
taxed a lot
and and and but so i noticed this
because in mexico i noticed a lot you're
either very poor or rich or decently
rich or very rich
and i see the spectrum in mexico because
with mexico it's a community thing they
come together and they rise together
same with black black communities
you mess with one of us you go like
conor mcgregor says when one of us goes
to war we all go to war
and i believe that's how it should be
minorities should be sticking together
um i even include white people it's like
you join with us because
immigrants built the nation that you're
in because i'm part native american
there's actually a lot of black people
who actually look at their roots they're
also native american as well
and and you notice that you know
just like you have to slaughter our kind
of people and the trail of tears and etc
to build the country that we're in now
you would expect to think that maybe you
would be more empathized and not put our
kids in our cages
because that's one of the things that
really did hurt me a lot as a person
that's a latino because i was noticing
different immigrants of different races
being put in cages and then the kids
disappear
and then you're wondering those are lost
generations now
so the future is as a children the
future is the youth
and they're the ones that are going to
decide whether you're a politician or
first responder military whatever
you're going to build and shape the
economy for what it is in the future
so it's it's in us but it's also all
together with us
yeah
and
yeah and by the way um
what you were saying uh
pearl
um
kevin samuel jessica's kevin
kevin samuel's definition of what a man
hey kevin seville's samuel's definition
of high value that is high value but i
don't think that just because somebody
doesn't check all his boxes they're not
high value you know what i'm saying
um well i think you have to have a
definition
and so i don't necessarily like
like i didn't didn't kevin samuels come
up with the term
yeah he did he came up with that
definition yeah he came up with that
wasn't
yeah so if we're talking about high
value men and i'm talking about kevin
samuels definition like like if you say
high value it doesn't mean like that the
person has no value it's just not in
that definition
yeah oh yeah you tell my his okay that's
true i was about to say cuz like because
i know people who make a lot of money
have a big network but just because
they're not this and that they're
automatically not high value like right
i wouldn't say also one thing i remember
you said one time
uh you were saying i wonder who's more
pergamos men or women um i won i i think
i i i was gonna comment this but i um i
just didn't for some reason i tell you
this hypergamy is not what what's my
best option hypergamy is this what's my
best option compared to me so if men
were hypergamous we would want women who
are taller than us make more money than
us and can provide that's what it would
be if we were hypergamous so yeah no i
what i meant is um in terms of looks
so like men tend to want the best
looking
like girl like because um i would say
like looks is to men is like maybe money
and statuses to women that's exactly
right yeah so
uh so when i say who's more hypergamous
men are women and what i'm saying is
who
like if if for a guy is he always
looking for the best looking option
right like like can you move up does
that make sense in the same way that a
woman is always trying to move up and
find the best like the highest status
male she can attain
we're not like that the reason why we're
not like i'm gonna break it down to you
as perfectly as i can okay so us as men
growing up
we i don't know if you've done this or
not
but you can say it to yourself how many
times have you walked up to a man that
you thought was hot hot
not cute hot
and you went up asked him for his number
and said i think you're really cute i'd
like to take you on a date to stay in
the other and charm them and been
confident in everything
if you've never done that we as men we
have to do that
and we have to deal with the pain of our
self-esteems being hurt our confidence
being jabbed at from getting rejected
also
we get told if if a dude who's a five
approaches a girl who's eight people
gonna be like dude why'd you even try
that you know you can't get her see
we're gonna get rid of whereas your
girlfriends would just lie to you and
stuff
so we as men we are very selective of
who we approach
so if a man the men we look heavily at
ourselves like it's very rare that a man
will look at a girl and just approach
just like that we look and we analyze
and we plot and we look at her and we
look at us and then we move
actually we don't just move what we say
no actually the one poll that actually
changed the way that i viewed this and i
actually i think women are more
hypergamous um and the reason i came to
this conclusion was i had a poll on my
channel and i said like was the x you
loved the most the best looking and it
was like 80 said no
and so it was just based on and i think
as women like we just assume it's
everything's based on looks like that's
just our automatic that's what we do we
compare to the last girl who's better
looking
yeah that's true um but yeah no we're
not because men we don't we don't have
that like for example back then if we
were living sticks and stones out in the
woods
um
let's say if squanto had fish and
rabbits he had a fence and he had a big
hut and your family you're hungry and
starving are you gonna stick with your
husband are you just gonna go with
squanto so the thing about us men is you
guys have more of an instinctual
proclaim to up and leave than we do
where we are wired to if we're in this
village if we don't stand strong we get
killed and eaten so we have more of a
proclivity to stay and remain loyal
while you all have more of a natural
it's a survival everything sexuality is
survival y'all have more of a proclivity
to up and leave to see if you can get
better just nowadays it's rampant like i
was telling you with me and the girls in
my college at my school how
if you weren't an athlete they wouldn't
deal with you and that's the thing
this is just college see how how
hypergamous they were without and
hypergamy's not wrong it's the lack of
accountability and self-reflection that
comes with right so yeah or itself or
gratitude even like a lot of girls think
they just deserve these guys and they
have to do nothing to attain them yeah
but then they haven't met
well i'm sorry
oh my god
uh
it's also a western concept too because
first of all countries they incentivize
by keeping people apart and
women are 80 of the consuming buying
products so there's a reason why the
fashion sense is the lingerie makeup uh
plastic surgery they will no never go
out of style nor the sex industry either
for men because men are very horny
sexual beings and then the libido
so that's why these industries will
never go out because incentivize to make
billions a year
so why would you all of a sudden shut
down something that in the economy
that's in debt while they do that when
incentivizes courts to split up families
and incentivize to divorce
so i think that's
that's a
a longer topic in itself but that's just
aspects of it and um
i think that's why a lot of society now
a lot of kids now are young
they lack respect and they take things
for granted from their parents
i see that a lot and then these younger
generations because myself i wasn't the
greatest but
i tell you what when my father
disciplined when i was younger it molded
me to respect the curfew respect the
time ask permission
do things if you said no then my bull my
parents said no it wasn't no if i defied
it and snuck out and got my ass whooped
rightfully so
they were worried sick it's just because
they were in the care they want you to
respect the rules of the house
um and i noticed that a lot especially
with like
i don't know how it was for you if you
got received any ass clothings as a you
know teenage daughter but at least for
boys we get our asses what if we mess up
with our parents
so and i think that's very important now
because at least a lot of kids now
to understand the gratitude because you
said yourself earlier your gratitude in
itself and being grateful
um
and the one thing i've actually noticed
with guys is the less i ask for the more
like i've always gotten
oddly enough like the last like
like some of the best gifts i've ever
gotten from a guy i did not ask for i
did not expect like it was just i don't
know random almost
um
mac what do you think our high value men
worth it
uh if it's high value in a sense of what
kevin samuel says makes so such amount
of money i think it's six figures making
it successfully i think for around six
years a few other yeah uh details that i
can't remember yeah right now kevin
samuel i said it at the beginning of the
live stream okay so in that sense uh i
don't think it's worth it uh no and i
think that because that's a very narrow
set of people and there are
naturally uh in this country they're
more women than men
and if you don't want to share a guy
which i most people are monogamous
so it's not really worth it and a few
reasons everyone else mentioned
um you know yeah factors such as
cheating
um
there are other less i would say morally
bankrupt um
costs such as you know if he's busy all
the time
which
you know can't have everything which
isn't inherently bad but if you're just
completely neglectful then that's uh
that's not exactly good
so i would say just from that uh uh
i i would say it's a pretty small amount
of people that it's uh or woman
or whoever i don't know
right pretty small amount of people that
would be so-called worth it
uh what do you think jay
oh first of all hey pearl i haven't seen
you in a while
i've been watching a couple of your
streams and i watched the stream i think
you did three days ago with mac and uh
figure out what's his name that wasn't
and um
yeah okay
yeah trust me well we all got dogs
yeah congrats like i said
congratulations on your success uh as
for your question
do i think they're worth it this is i've
been thinking for the average woman for
the average one the average woman yes
for the average woman
no
no and here's why
and here's why
because that
only a celeb a select few women
probably can get into get into that
range but they have to they have to jump
up to
eights and tens which i think
is not likely but
they can they can improve
and that improvement can only go to a
certain level mm-hmm and um it's
it's a numbers game and i hate to get
into it but
you you are what you put out and if you
put out what you put out you're gonna
get you're gonna get what you apply for
mm-hmm simple enough when it comes to
that
but it it's more of a matter of
that like you're missing like let's be
real the i the high value man
he may have all of this but if he likes
character then if you lay if you like
character over the average man then what
does that tell you about
tell you about you
it means that you just you value the
hypergamous side more than you value
character
you know
and not to throw shade but that would
make you a gold digger in that sense if
you're just going right honey
but
i'm i just gotta throw shade when i need
to throw it because that's just it's
just true that's not gonna be going
after her i'll make it sure but it's
like me going after a girl just because
she's pretty and that's all i see in her
no
i look like i'm looking for a prettiness
character and personality those are the
three things i care about
and if and she has the qualities of a
mother that before of course
but um
but yeah
well it's interesting because i just see
all these women talk about how they want
high value men on kevin samuels channel
and my dad
i don't know if he's high value or mana
value so i think it just would probably
depend who you ask but
i don't think most girls understand the
amount of work that it takes to date one
of these guys
you don't just get to sit at home and be
a housewife like they expect something
in return
mm-hmm
and um pearl to touch on that um you to
touch on your father so you said you
don't know if he's a high-value man or
he's a man of great value let me ask you
a question
what would you say that he is based on
all the time he spends with whatever
time he spends with you and things like
that
well
he doesn't have the linkedin levels of
visibility because he doesn't have
social media
so that's why i question it because he
doesn't he doesn't like social media he
doesn't have it
so that makes me think okay maybe he's
not but then the second thing like the
network
he has
but he doesn't really like we we've
never been the type to go to like
like preppy events you know like i don't
know how to describe it but hi i
wouldn't call us high class
in the sense that
we run in like the ivy league crowd like
i wouldn't put us there does that make
sense like i would put this below that
so
i i don't know if he would be
i'd say he's close does that make sense
i'd say somewhere in between
and that's why he'd be giving me a bit
of character and great value
my dad my dad has the best character
i've ever seen in a person he never
drank doesn't have social media like he
literally just works
like that's and that doesn't yeah and
that's why i don't follow me personally
i don't follow
i think what kevin describes as high
value is high value but that's why i
don't follow kevin
because if somebody's not high value
just because they don't have a social
media but they got a big eight figure
company and networks like come on man
like or if somebody has a big company
but they don't have a network yet but
they got the social media like come on
you can't do that
i mean yeah you can't because it it
it completely objectifies the other uh
objective
if you're if you're trying to go based
off that i'm just saying like because
they they're in a different field of
requirement for most people and not many
people can attain that like i like for
example i work two jobs to be average
i'm like i'm like average i'm like
middle class almost
pretty much but the thing is i'm
struggling to be a little higher but i
ain't doing it the thing is i'm not
doing this looking at my options i'm
doing it so i could be at a better place
that's all i really care about because
like i said family and legacy that's all
i really care about
and
and you know
a woman that is who is worried enough to
raise my offspring is what i really is
really what i give
two craps about
because the thing is she doesn't have to
i'll tell pearl right now pearl she
could be a six or five i'd be okay
you just
that's the one thing that i've actually
has really surprised me in the man of
spirit because again as girls we always
think it's about looks and what i've
realized is what it seems like a girl
just has to meet like a guy's basic
minimum threshold of a girl he would
date and then it's more about how she
treats him would you say that's right
and it's not necessarily like the
hottest girl that the guys like love the
most because
um there's a certain type of girl that a
guy would just sleep with because she's
hot but like he doesn't want to spend
more than
the time he's sleeping with with her
right she probably likes some other
things is what it is and yeah i want i
want to speak on that because i don't
think they talk about that enough in rp
i would say that she probably just
contributing that and that's all she
came in with because she had some
qualities of being a mom i'll be honest
if she says yo my father did such and
such
and i respect him very highly if she
talks about her father that means you've
got something guys i want to let you
right now she talks about her father
like yeah he did like i without him i
wouldn't be here i love him this much
and all that guys technically do have a
wooden area in that court but the thing
is you have to show the father that
you're more than well enough to date his
daughter because i'm very territorial if
i ever had a daughter i'm like yeah you
got to show
not her you got to kill me well and
that's why i actually think girls have
so much of an opportunity nowadays to
attain a guy that's actually above their
like looks level
um or even socioeconomic because girls
are just so bad nowadays it seems like
like i've just heard from guy after guy
how frustrated they are with dating
and i've what i've noticed is a lot of
girls if they have like
if they
carry themselves a certain way are
actually able to do like quite well
and there's i would say more
opportunities for girls to i'm not
saying girls take those opportunities
because a lot of girls just like do
nothing until they're out of time
but
but what i've noticed is that um
girls nowadays have more opportunity i
think because a lot of girls just like
you know are for the streets is that a
good word
can i jump one real quick with that
um now and i don't i don't know
interact with your personal life you
know i'm not going to get into it i
think yeah a little bit with that is
just
um kind of who do we surround ourselves
around because you know we talk a lot
about you know hypergamy it's out of
control
it's you know modern woman this all that
sort of stuff
um
one thing
and well actually two things so the
first thing i think that we all uh think
we all just need to do a better job with
society is like we kind of need to get
rid of a little bit of these
victim um
mentalities you know one of the guys
sides is you know oh it's her pro uh
it's you know women only care about you
know height we only they only care about
looks they only care about how you
perform the bed all this stuff um well
if that's the case for you i'm i'm truly
sorry if like for a lot of guys if
that's the case well you know and a
greater deal i mean i'm currently a
college student so trust me like any
anybody talks about on
but you gotta youtube to surroundings
but and so and pro you mentioned earlier
you know kind of like a lot of uh women
on kevin's uh daniel's live streams
he'll talk about okay you know i want
like a high uh by guy and all that and
stuff and i mean i get it i can't say
they're lying because it happens but to
speak to that um kevin summons does his
streams what typically around
10 p.m 11 p.m and eastern time
okay let's let's just let's just i'm
gonna interrupt you for a second there's
one two three four five guys um on the
stream on the count of three i want you
all to say what percentage of women
today you think are wife material i'm
gonna do one one one at a time one at a
time yeah no no no no i'm all at this
same time i'm gonna say one two three
and everyone say what percent so if you
meet 10 women what percent are wife
material like you would marry them
so ready three two one go twenty ten
seconds one to two one to two
damn that's right
okay so this is five guys that like
don't that don't know oh by the way what
up jay what up jay right
now and and this is coming from someone
i grew up around girls that are pretty
involved in sports i wouldn't say most
of my friends are super like hoe or
ratchet like i
i most of my friends are athletes to be
honest but i mean it's you can't see
this whole community and not recognize
there is an issue
i i get it it's like real though like
it's ridiculous like uh i would and i
mean when i say this i mean it a decent
woman i didn't say good i didn't say
great i said a decent woman is top 20
i would say a decent and the reason why
and if you ask me how what percentage of
men do i think is marriageable i would
give it easily between 60 and 70
because straight off the bat yeah
almost every man
would rather and now it's not this
extreme for lack of better words most
men would rather die than not provide
for their family most men would take a
bullet for
anybody in their household most men
[Music]
most men
like
most if you see a car two cars in the
driveway one's a 2020 and the other
one's 2003. the man is going to get the
woman a new car before he gets himself
one like
men what men want to make their wives
happy like that you know what i'm saying
but you don't find women who were vice
how many women
would
die to keep their family together
you know what i'm saying it's just you
know yeah
and it's funny yeah one last thing i had
to say
my cousin is actually high value he's vp
of a big company he just got a new
promotion literally like two days ago
he's on my man it's funny kevin samuels
talks about getting married in six
months he married both of his wives in
six months and he cheated on his first
one and that's why she left him and it's
so amazing because he's the exact image
of what kevin the
of mergers acquisitions the six feet six
figure earner cheating oh my god that's
the thing yeah
every people in my family making jokes
like his wife is like a six at best and
he'll be somehow she looks older than
him which she does
but she makes up in other qualities so
yeah
oh can i can i add that can i can i add
off that j yeah go ahead j j what did i
say the six and sevens they most likely
make the best
wives members
we said that remember six and sevens and
a few eights don't make the best wives
because these nines and tens they're ego
they're lazy they may not want to cook
and clean and listen and be obedient
56 and sevens guess what but let's say
for example the average attractive small
town girl is going to be more humble
than the higher status city market city
chick
because even though there are still
average girls in these small towns being
flown out you'll still find a higher
chance a higher percentage of a woman
that's humble that's attractive
um uh mediocrity or six or seven or
eight maybe
in those small towns or small cities as
opposed to the high market like i was on
a different stream and i said this out
loud i said oh it was on dr redfield's i
was it was saying um
the four horsemen of the apocalypse the
cities are new york las vegas miami and
l.a those are the four horsemen
the four horsemen because all of these
places have what porn stars only fans
celebrities the the rappers the the
boxers you know even though i love
boxing but
a lot of these what all these um have is
a trade it's like a trade-off so
obviously
the clout the money the status and i
remember there was a question they asked
ladies and they said
would you rather pick a man who has
power or money and emphatically what do
they say they want the man that has
power
because power is great
oh my god that is that is what i said on
they did not believe me
wait wait i uh
they when i was on um donovan sharp's
podcast as i was saying it is not the
same thing
to
a guy that just has money versus a guy
um like versus a guy that
has influence and i was telling you yeah
because he did not but he did not
believe me i was like these rappers like
that get quick like money like that are
not the same as like the vp of
acquisitions and mergers i'm sorry
it is not the same thing
yeah because a person a person can have
money and not have power but a person
that has power will usually have money
as well
um
and and the thing about power is
there's few and absolute that do have
power for example
um the military there's one general
above all the generals because even
though there's multiple generals there's
one top general of all
that runs it the same way there's one
president of the country
and these are what not just status but
one point power
so uh status and power are two different
things they can co-insist but there are
two different things in general for
example high value man you can't be a
heavenly man without good character high
quality you can't be that like that's
how what i believe if you can correct me
from wrong doc kevin sam is gonna
correct me if i'm wrong other these top
correct
i'll go for it man
can i jump in real quick so i'll just uh
just answer like two things you said
real quick um do you consider atlanta
because that's right i'm from right now
um
or where i live right now do you
consider like one of those four cities
kind of i believe we said la uh i
believe miami was one of them can't
remember
miami yeah what what i mean what i mean
when it comes to that mac is the
betrayal and media the movie the shows
the video the videos even though atlanta
is known for its rappers and some actors
and tv shows and stuff
but it's still not on the same scale as
miami new york vegas and la because they
all have these things because believe me
i live a few hours away from la
believing some of these top content
creators i i run into joe rogan i shook
hands and talked with them i'm still
trying to get on this podcast sooner or
later like live with him in person but
um
uh yeah like these uh the these these
people around here they they move
differently
it's more of a business they have every
handshake every handshake i always say
it's like you shake a politician's hands
treat it carefully and look at them with
like a question mark in the back of your
head because even though he's looking at
you as a nice person just like i treat
politicians whenever i shake their hands
it's like i'm 50 50 on you because
you could be for the media for just for
the news for the cover but behind closed
doors you're an [ __ ] a piece of [ __ ]
not trying to help the economy or
nothing
or you're not trying to help your people
i just mentioned that because you know
i've lived in atlanta from like most of
my life uh and when everyone's talking
about like you know we have all these
shits are getting flown out all this
place you know and you know okay so
we've established atlantis maybe not to
the same level to other cities but like
i mean like we got to give us throw us a
little credit here i mean we got magic
city where you know every hawks player
goes to i know they lost the east
eastern uh
championship last year but or this year
technically but
i mean so there's still you know
shakers and hustlers out here but like
everyone's talking about like you know
you know all these women getting flown
out i'm like and we have the second
business airport and up in the world and
i'm like i don't i don't see it
i mean
i wear glasses for a reason so i don't
know if it's just me being a mouse but
like
i don't know i mean
it highlighted
it highly depends on the circles you run
in like
i don't know any girl that gets flown
out like genuinely because i i i know
athletes
i know girls have gone flown out
yeah yeah but i'm saying i'm saying like
you can't you can't deny it doesn't it
doesn't exist yeah it of course happens
i just questioned kind of like what to
what extent because i feel like it's
like very easy to kind of get caught up
in circles where it's like all you see
well it's easy and it's pretty easy to
tell because you can you can see it look
at a girl's instagram what message is
she sending out they have to see
something to fly out
yeah
yeah and i it's either you see them in
an expensive restaurant wearing some
type of sexual like advertisement for
their only fans they're half naked
they're partying which i understand if
you're young getting and live your live
enjoy the fruits of your labors but
your perception is also key at times as
well perception is key so us guidance
we're going to look at that as oh she's
a smashing dash chick so we'll smash
them will dash
you know it's it's either great value or
high value so for us we'll look at the
girl's great value even though she's
attractive on the high part
but for great value for relationship
that's what she is like walmart brand so
we'll just smash pump and dump and
that's it and i hate to put it that way
but us guys we have to be also very
careful and selective of the women we
tend to move around with for me because
of my latino household i have to be very
careful with who i show in front of my
nephews and nieces i don't want to be
known as the guy who's constantly
bringing a woman over and over again and
introducing to my mom and dad because
that's going to breed uh oh well then my
own can do it and my niece especially
for my nieces if my uncle can do it i'm
going to want to do that i can bring a
boy around as much as i want i can bring
different men around no because
i have to be very careful if this is the
trick that i'm going to take serious and
she's not going to make a fool out of me
and i know that i'm going to bring her
around my mother and they're going to
lay down their guard to trust this woman
i'm going to make sure this one does not
try to destroy me
yeah so we're talking about yeah
earlier bro
would you say oh sorry um
i'm still thinking about the fact how
how he was talking about how many of our
marriage material just like this man
marcus was saying right here
you just ask yourself how many women
have a deep first of all how many women
know what men want as simple as they are
if you don't even know what we want as
simple as we are and if you can't even
go to the gym
what in the world that takes away like
70 of women on the back
the one thing is i think girls we have
been given such bad information like
that is actually one of the reasons that
i started watching kevin samuels was
because
the way he puts it he he breaks it down
so simply from a guy's point of view and
as women especially like when you're
younger you're just confused because
some guys are telling you they like like
they like you thick right how many how
many of you guys have hooked up with
like a chubby a chubby girl no be honest
be honest i've hooked up with i've
hooked up with the slim thick chick and
a in a few thick chicks not like obese
like 200 but maybe like 180 175
yeah
like that
and and you don't necessarily like the
younger you are like girls just lie to
each other and they say go do your own
thing whatever
and uh like luckily like i i was raised
with like a mom that
like for example she never let me get a
tattoo she like there's a lot of stuff i
wasn't like allowed to do
oh my god i was so mad i want to get one
so bad when i was 18. no no no no no no
no no
i got three i'm trying to get like three
more
i mean there's nothing wrong with that
but like as kevin samuel says like if
you get a tattoo as a girl like you're
off the table for a lot of guys so like
why do that to yourself
um where like men get tattoos and it
makes them more masculine i tell girls
this do not get the trash stamp do not
get the training stamps that's what i
tell girls avoid the [ __ ] stamp
because that's just going to breed a
stereotype
i would say for the most part for men uh
we tend to get different type of tattoos
but especially if you're like my age and
you're like some
let's say larger guy and you're just
like walking around you're balding i
mean i'm [ __ ] balding and you have
like a tribal and it looks like you have
nothing going on then it's like uh so
it was kind of like nothing if you have
no muscle behind it that's what i've
always said even if you do have muscle
because a lot of guys with tribals have
are pretty jacked but like you just
yeah
try
but tribal tattoos where i'm not trying
to get out but trouble tattoos with a
thing like 10 years ago
no offense like tribal tattoos were the
thing like 10 years ago
um and it's like because i remember i
was a good video on getting some but i
got some japanese in chinese and i got
um
i put till i die my v and my abdominal
on the v till i die with the initials of
my grandparents
so that's what i got for a tattoo and
then i got another tattoo i'm trying to
get like a leg sleeve or arm sleeve if i
can but that's gonna take a while to
pick but that's just my preference um
but the woman if she were to have one or
two tattoos there's no problem it's just
how she carries herself is what's
ultimately gonna get me that's how she
carries herself so she trusts to be
disrespectful in public loud obnoxious
i'm just gonna ghost you right there
i'll just walk out in my car and i'll be
like oh hell no
then i'll go i'm out
i'm out
and the thing is like the thing that i
think
like i've had so
like my last boyfriend he told me the
reason that he dated me was because i
was just really really nice and i feel
like girls don't understand how just
being like really nice and thoughtful
for a guy and like
like surprising him with things like
being helpful to him goes so far
but we're not you're not taught that in
school you're told like you're the prize
like he should be like fighting for you
yeah yeah and i think the thing that the
pushback on that is um
i think women honestly if you if you
look into our mindset of just being
simple when we get home from at the
school or work
we just want to chill have a good time
like just talk or watch the game and
watch a movie with you and then we'll
eat together and then if you want to
talk a little bit to me i'll let you
vent to me grind my shoulder or talk
about whatever drama was happening to
your family and your friends
vent to me because i'm there i'm your
rock to leon
but you can be the you can be the woman
um as much as i want to be the soft
pillow i'll be your rock you know that's
how i put it so for men they want the
one to be the soft pillow to lay next to
and then for men will be the strong rock
for you to protect you and to hear you
right there will be the barrier we'll be
the berry and children right
why you like i said why you are you're
the flower that we protect yeah there
you go like protecting the goat
sorry i'm just confused marcus do you
is what does that have to do with being
nice you just said like on the other end
so i was just confused well the the nice
the nice part is the woman being the
flower and the respectful nice guy
if he really is a true man if the woman
will respect it because a woman has to
understand and respect that if a woman
cannot understand respect the fact that
a man is willing to listen to you here
you vent
and come from his long day of work and
then you know sit down with you have
dinner with you talk to you
just have the time that's a good nice
guy but also a respectful man is one to
listen to you women take that for
granted sometimes well i was talking
about um like the girl being nice yeah
like like if you're a girl and you're
nice it goes a long way
okay yeah yeah well look like like jay
said yeah jay said the flower the flower
yeah
i think we agree i just thought you said
you disagreed so i was trying to figure
out if you did but i think no no no i
think we're on the same page
the only reason why i say push back was
because i was adding more context to it
in detail because we leave out sometimes
certain details fair enough yeah that's
horrible i just go ahead pearl
yeah
i got i have a question
i asked you um most girls this question
and the answer kind of surprises me
okay
i asked um which one would they which
one would they rather have a guy who is
capable of cheating but chooses not to
or a guy who could cheat even who
couldn't even cheat even if he could
most um most girls chose the guy who who
could cheat but chooses not to
yeah you don't i mean you don't want a
guy that no one else wants because it's
like it's like why would i why would i
want someone that no one else wants
because then you think like why does no
one else want him like
girls
girls select men for a reason
yeah i know that but like what happened
in high school
what that was so funny i said i had she
had that situation happen to me in high
school when i was on the um track team
for a year
i literally had um literally had two
girls trying to um no one girl tried to
pull me from another girl that was
trying to like crush on me
and they were just like trying to she
was like trying to take me from her and
i'm just like with the freak and and
then i get i get hit with this
i get hit like caught in the like boy's
locker room and she just walks in on and
says yo
yo i'll leave your girl for me i'm like
huh
but she's wilding
we should have said misogyny
i don't think i knew the word at the
time but they never happened to me in
high school
yeah it happens a lot with guys in
sports like if you're in the football
team if you're on the track team
especially if you're on the swim team
like dude
if if you're like one of the top like
jocks or whatever or like a noticeable
jock
they will come to you but the thing is
that's because that's where like the
popularity is that
yeah
i was also an athlete in high school too
i was i played football
what you're saying about the athlete
thing is true while girls going near
athletes and stuff well only like the
top the top percenters in the athlete
i was i was also an athlete so i have
the experience
it's
they only go off like the top percenters
and like the
who they know is the best on the team
basically
yeah so for example what john what john
is saying is um uh the the top athlete
who is a good looking guy who looks like
he has the complete package who has the
body who has a handsome face who has the
game who is like the top athlete he'll
most likely get the top of the top of
the pick
um and i knew a few guys in each
graduating class who had that it was
small few and handfuls here and there
but like i said it goes you want to take
it down to statistics
we can all break down a lot of women if
you can choose each graduating class
they chose the top guy it was only a
small handful of guys that can pull that
off
only a small handful of guys and each
graduating class had that it's just that
women think that just because these guys
are doing it a lot of guys can pull it
off and that's the biggest lie
and you know just because girls can get
easy access to sex doesn't mean men can
i'm not complaining we're not crying
about it we just want to lay down the
formula there's a formula to it you got
to respect the formula it is what it is
well if uh for example god can bless me
with
um decent handsomeness but i'm a super
smart guy and i can excel in my career
and then and be a successful rich
businessman
um there's my value in that
uh but let's say for example jay he's
very athletic he's built well and he
becomes he excels in that
and he may be decent averagely smart
which i'm not saying is not because he's
a computer tech
but you know
uh
he can excel in that and that's his
power we all have certain powers that we
have that we can excel at
but i think the one thing we do have
control is um
the level of status you want to rise to
i think that's what we definitely do
have control over looks we have control
over as well but even if we do some of
those guys get in shape and get ripped
some guys out there will still struggle
because they have a lat game they're
still not as attractive looking you know
they have a good body i noticed that in
itself
well i've actually i went to um a pickup
conference
um
yeah where guys
i keep promising my followers the videos
coming out soon and i still swear it is
but i have a little blur
no i need to learn how to blur faces and
i'm very bad at it so it's taking me
forever but um
yeah some of the guides were like
i didn't think they'd be this down bad
like i didn't realize how
no no no no i mean like they're they
were decent looking like they're tall
and like i didn't when i talked to them
i didn't think like oh there's something
clearly wrong like wrong with you here
like why you're not getting girls or
having such a hard time with this so it
really like shocked me
like i just could really see it from
their point of view because i was trying
to help him i was like go talk to her
talk to her talk to her and what i
noticed is the most average looking
girls would reject these guys and it
wasn't even the hottest girls that would
be the meanest to them
hey man hey like i said that happened
what the hell were there not surprised
what what's happening it was big it was
in vegas
have you guys
can have a quick question have all you
guys seen the movie the 4-year-old
virgin
yes yeah i believe so remember that
speed this the speed
what the [ __ ] the speed dating scene
yeah you remember the speed dating
yeah the speed dating scene was bad so
if that's how you describe it pearl yeah
guys will struggle especially guys if
they haven't gotten late in a while they
will struggle again it'll be like kind
of an anxiety thing
um yeah and they want to make sure they
can be as cool as common collected but
when they try so hard it'll break the
ice and then that's when they get very
anxious and nervous so i say guys like
i will
i will say this guys take a drink or
just relax and chill and be mellow as
possible be confident but be mellow and
then just lay back sit down you ask the
woman a question and let her answer just
let her speak and then you find out more
about her before you find before she
finds out more about you that way you
have mysterious facade
yeah don't
yeah all your
interests
well for me since i'm dealing with asd
autism spectrum disorder
uh well game and all of that i'm not too
keen on picking that up most of the time
i'm just
direct
i just say whatever
pops into my head
and most of the time
most of the time it worked yeah aiming
to lie
most of the time she found it funny most
of the time she kept talking i was like
yeah it weren't
yeah i mean of course you could be
direct but um it also depends on the
type of woman that's willing to be able
to handle that directness
because it also depends on the
demographic a woman is percentages so
for every five women maybe only one can
handle that direction that directiveness
so you know it's just like that so in
your in your experience that's awesome
but for a lot of guys they can't really
be that direct even if they try like for
example hypothetically pearl like i
found you attractive i want to take you
out so we can smash later that's not
really gonna happen because she's gonna
take it as i go oh [ __ ] like well relax
man
what what what the [ __ ]
but
but the way you get it
but
no but you gotta understand though
you gotta understand john like i
understand you were going through this
asd because i've worked with kids that
have like asd teenagers etc so the the
directiveness the direct that they're
being direct like that
women say they want the truth but they
honestly can't always handle the truth
so if a guy were to say hey i like you
but i want to smash
um i find you very attractive a lot of
girls will be like you gotta whine and
die me you gotta fly me out we gotta go
to resort well i think it depends on on
who the girl is
to be honest because a lot a lot of
girls find that directness attractive
like a lot a lot of girls do but if a
girl is looking for a relationship or
something more long-term obviously she's
gonna run like uh yeah but if a girls
look like some girls go out looking for
hookups
yeah that's what it is i was going to
jump in real quick because uh john i
think uh we haven't talked much i think
we're very similar uh you know a lot of
people talk about game and that's
completely fine you know i understand of
course i mean i'm in school
to learn how to do something i want to
accomplish but for me um and it just
goes into previous stream my general
lack of patience now and
for me i'm fairly direct now i won't be
like um like super super blunt or i
won't be so weird about it but if it's
just like a casual thing it's like
look hey you know it's 3 p.m or 3 a.m
well sometimes 3 p.m but if it's 3 in
the morning i'm like look we all know
what time it is like
um i'm
let's not let's not play dom let's just
yeah it's just happening or not if
there's no that's cool like yeah a lot
of women don't want to like have that
such directness but here's the thing
you don't you're not trying to date
every woman you're not trying to have
well you're not trying to have sex with
every woman so it can only be two
percent three percent four percent
that's cool because you you literally do
not have enough time in a day or time
alive to worry about all the mother
tongues just
and just i just focus like you can kind
of like follow down the edges a little
bit you don't want to be super abrasive
but you got to be yourself at the end of
the day so like i mean yeah
i've noticed that the more abrasive a
guy is and the less he filters it and
waters it down like the more attractive
women tend to find it
just might
it just for me on that take i think it's
just it's give and take depending on the
woman like you said mm-hmm i think it's
a defense for the right audience
right so oh yeah depending on the genre
or the spectrum of the group i get you
um i i just think the only thing is um
for example like
like i want to romanticize you let's
let's have a passion i want let us
fornicate you know like stuff like that
isn't gonna be corny it's gonna be corny
as hell
but don't don't do that
but
yeah
yeah and
but like
it just sometimes girls like a funny
goofy guy they like that and i've
noticed that too and some some of the
time i was a funny guy i like being
funny
um yeah
having in shape body helps and
speaking multiple languages and being
different culture wise that helps as a
bonus especially when you start speaking
in that sexual language of spanish or
french
it helps um
you know
yeah because you're just playing
competence and like i feel like girls
want to be taken on an adventure so the
more interesting like places you've been
or like yeah i'll take you on adventure
and jump on my pogo stick yeah that's an
adventure
damn
that's clever really clever
yeah i was like let's go on the carousel
ride the cc carousel
um
the weird thing is most of the time what
well let's go now so y'all decided
oh no the weird thing is most of the
time girls have approached me
that's the that's the weird part
sometimes that happened unexpectedly
it approached me i never really
approached now most of the time they
approached me which was kind of was kind
of like oh this really happens
it really happens if they approached me
did you go for the girls that approached
you
yeah
i mean yeah yeah
yeah i've noticed that like
like girls that seem to
not have trouble approaching seem to
have more luck in dating because if
they're not afraid to like
i don't tell the guy
would you guys agree or disagree do you
guys like to be approached
right
can i be more guys basically like
shooting on a goal with no goalkeeper
it's like i mean it's not hard yeah
because us
us guys we're all sexual beings so we
know that for a fact that it's going to
become an easier accomplishment
to at least lay with the chick you know
so if you live with the chick either
that way she knows that okay i know for
a fact this woman is cutting it short
she's getting directly to the point she
finds me attractive i know for a fact
this is at least going to lead to sex
and if it can and it'll blossom into a
relationship so i'm the kind of guy that
likes both we can either have a friend
who benefits her relationship i like
both i like to go on dinner dates or
movies or something like that but i also
like to make memories of the person but
i also don't mind if it's just sex and i
focus on my job my business yeah
you know so
i'll say for me it's very content
depending if it's like a old or
so-called quote-unquote friend that i
need to know and she was like hey you
know kind of want to you know kick it up
on that notch i'm not sure but a lot of
times i've been kind of in a bar in a
club and like it comes up to me like
we're kind of like those eyes like i
really need something from you right now
and i'm just like uh okay and like
usually most of the time it's like some
guys follow me around i can get rid of
this dude or other time you know it's a
much better of course it's just trying
to sell me uh crack so it's like okay
i'm waiting to hear a girl i'm i'm
always like
oh
if it's like in a club or a bottom line
i was like okay what the [ __ ] do you
want from me
no if it's something
i was just gonna say i i want a girl to
approach mac and just be like let us
[ __ ] and i'm like i want to see what you
do i want to see what you do
there was a girl there was a girl who
did that on youtube she approached guys
and asked to like have sex with them and
it was oh i think i know that youtube
channel yeah it was the
um i want to say over 80 percent i don't
remember exactly
yeah ah
set it higher if a woman comes
i will say that some guys will be like
i'm maybe not snatched but maybe a
peepee touch or a bj or something like
that you know saying
you know
they might do that
you know yes if a girl walks i'm looking
out for that hemp like
yeah i just say guys be careful i also
say guys test yourselves clean
yourselves make sure
you're very responsible don't get a girl
pregnant and make sure you don't pass
the disease because in the health
spectrum of it a lot of stds are
hibernating and dormant for the first
four to five years
um they can come back to bite you later
so that's why i say be very careful so
even though yeah college is supposed to
be a good time
um be very wise because a lot of stds
are transmitted a lot of times from
colleges as well that's why the
fraternities and sororities they're the
worst
oh yeah
you already know you already know
they're the worst
i'm not i don't i didn't
i'm on my way to college oh god
yeah just be smart man i'm just saying
that don't i'm not saying don't live a
little but be smart and be careful
that's the one thing i will tell both
sexes
especially women don't get especially
women that sleep around when i hear they
don't get tested regularly
um because you're playing with your
fertility ladies you get the wrong std
you're playing with your fertility yeah
a lot of well actually the majority of
the way like the majority i was gonna
see the majority of patients that go
into a clinic ninety percent of them are
women so
it's yeah i kind of get your point but
at the same time i don't at the same
time because i understand women are a
lot of them do get the std at the same
time they too try to get medicated for
it so i will give them that i will give
them that a credit for women
because men men don't go as much men do
not go
oh um
i wasn't really saying that to compare
what i was saying is i know a decent
amount of girls that sleep around and
don't get tested like between partners
and i'm saying if you're having casual
sex like you are playing with your
fertility like you you you you get the
wrong std you you can't have kids so be
careful
what is this
i mean i'm not
i'm not like saying all my friends are
like this i'm just i've met girls that
are you know i will i will say this
because i remember when i graduated boot
camp the like second to last day
they were giving us um
these farewells slideshow like pointers
and classes
and one of them was
um
careful the stds because a lot of women
they like to have fun with military man
they find military men extracted or
sexual whatever they'll approach you
um or you'll approach them and a lot of
men that have contracted diseases in the
service in foreign countries or
or domestic
they've shown some really trippy stds
where
guys are growing roots like little like
tree roots down there mushrooms and [ __ ]
like that like i'm not dying like some
of these things where they can go to the
cdc for this [ __ ] like
walking dead type stuff last of us
yeah like some of this [ __ ] was like
crystallized warts and [ __ ] down there
on the penis in the vagina
but this is health this is just health
education and science of it so we'd be
surprised with the what the body can go
through
and we can put it through so
it's that shows graphic
oh my god i
have to experience that um like watching
that i would a good thing i'm short yeah
no
i was gonna i was just saying because
man like like you'd be surprised the uh
the level of
what god and science can do to your body
with with punishment with punching
consequences
i had a guy roommate in college i once
saw him bring home four different girls
in a week and i just remember thinking
like what
girls got pregnant
oh [ __ ]
he would joke constantly about how he
didn't use condoms like all the time he
would like brag about it and i'm just
sitting there and i'm just sitting there
like
okay joe like you're playing and the
majority of a majority of stds that
originated were from anal anal sex anal
pleasure
a lot of it same as hiv aids and like
others a lot of stds originated from
anal
anal anal sexual no no penetration never
see me do that [ __ ] like literally yeah
that's why that's why a girl
i've had women where in the middle of
sex and she's like i want you to blow me
up my derriere and i'm like i'm out bye
and i left one time in the middle of it
your uber's here you gotta go
yeah
lucky i'm short
like i'm more likely to get rejected
anyway so i'm
oh my god okay guys
um i'm gonna end this live stream i was
trying to keep it an hour and a half and
i'm not even gonna lie we are not an
hour and 29 minutes
it's completely
cool we're not
entitled to
like doing this oh i know i'm just
letting you guys know um
but thank you so much for coming on i
really
i really appreciate it please call in
again um i would be very bored if it was
just me on here i don't think i could
talk for this long so i appreciate all
of you i'll make sure an apartment
are you what sport are you still in
volleyball on basketball or
yeah volleyball and basketball
are you guys going to come on tv or
anything a certain network on youtube or
something
um i live stream my games most um
wednesdays and saturdays
okay but no is it on a network no it's
not i have one small quick question do
they pay you because you're paying for
physical like semi-professional or
something or over natural international
scenes
i get a scholarship for the school
um and then
england is typically like a stepping
stone to
play pro so i think i could get a pro
contract next year if i wanted one um
pro contracts don't
really typically recruit d3 athletes and
i was d3
so um even though i was a really
competitive division three school they
don't know the difference so you
typically have to go to england for a
year to go pro
yeah that's why i have fun with the fish
and chips over there
fish and chest blood
in it
yeah
all right guys
that's why you're in england now
yeah that's why i'm in england
well take care guys happy holidays
everyone be safe have a merry christmas
and a happy new year if i don't get to
talk to you guys before the end of the
year so
jay i don't know if you're listening i
know you're on me brother i'll talk to
you later
um and yeah and best of luck to pearl to
your uh athletic career and i don't know
if you're still with angry reacts and i
hope the best if you guys are still
together
um
john wish you the best uh mac you too
man do your thing
yeah no no no no no no no butt plugging
if you know what i mean keep it youtube
sensitive
i'm not a digger bro i can't do it
all right guys good night bye guys